the snyder cut of justice league has
been a part of superhero conversation
since the joss whedon theatrical cut of
the film released back in 2017.
in may 2020 we found out the snyder cut
was real
and really headed to hbo max snyder told
the hollywood reporter at the time it
will be an
entirely new thing and especially
talking to those who have seen the
released movie
a new experience apart from that movie
he's back
with a rumored 20 to 30 million dollars
in additional funding from warner
brothers
snyder set to work using updated cgi and
the approximately 214 minutes worth of
footage
snyder had in the camp most of which we
supposedly haven't seen
there have been extensive conversations
about what will appear in the hbo max
exclusive
lex luthor martian manhunter superman in
his infamous black suit
and of course big baddie darkseid but in
the dark
among the stars the snyder cut is still
set for an unknown 2021 release date
but we now have a full trailer courtesy
of dc fandom
what made it into the trailer what might
have you missed even on your fifth
re-watch
let's break down the new justice league
trailer
we knew from the start that there would
be more of the heroes we already
saw in the theatrical cut but this
justice league trailer gives us a taste
of just how much more
two of the characters we hoped we'd see
elaborated on were vic stone
aka cyborg and barry allen better known
as the flash
the two represent a relatively minor
part of the theatrical version of
justice league when compared with batman
and wonder woman
but that's looking to change in a big
way that's the plan
that's the plan
okay we're not first up cyborg
we get clips of vic stone prior to his
transformative accident showing him
playing football at gotham city
university
that moment is contrasted shortly after
with a scene of vic
as cyborg tearing up a grave and
previous reports have indicated
it's his grave but there's also a blink
and you'll miss it moment featuring vic
from behind in his varsity jacket
moving an onslaught of missiles with a
wave of his hand and most shocking of
all
we see vic's father silas stone
seemingly disintegrating while working
on a mother box
the flash is looking to get a massive
upgrade in the snyder cut too
within moments of seeing barry in the
trailer we watch him save iris west
a character who was completely cut from
the theatrical version of justice league
there are also shots of flash running
through what looks like it could be the
speed force
at one moment barry is standing in a
desolate wasteland as energy waves wash
over
we've heard time travel will be involved
in the snyder cut is this moment related
even though batman wonder woman and
aquaman were already a major part of the
theatrical cut of justice league that
doesn't mean there isn't more to see
from them
for batman there are quick scenes
featuring him fighting off parademons
along with the batmobile being attacked
by them for wonder woman one of her big
moments involves finding a mysterious
arrow smouldering in the ground you
could mistake it for the spear superman
used to kill doomsday but it looked
suspiciously similar to an
arrow used by the amazon warriors as for
aquaman
it's looking an awful lot like his
storyline denying his role as atlantis
true leader
remains in place from the theatrical cut
there is a few shots of him drinking
and angrily tearing off his shirt but
the most important moment is where we
see his atlantean
armor on the floor of the ocean as he
backs away from meera
if your eyes are very fast though you'll
also clock what appears to be an
atlantean king
in full royal regalia including a
trident and a crown
is that a new version of the flashback
sequence from the theatrical cut
let's talk superman though because this
trailer sure does show him in his black
suit walking through what appears to be
the kryptonian vessel we first saw
back in man of steel we see superman in
the black suit again
fighting what appears to be steppenwolf
most importantly we see what looks like
a different version of clark's reunion
with lois and martha
after his resurrection you remembered
this is home if there's one thing that
snyder cut fans have been absolutely
frothing over
it's the reinsertion of justice league's
big bad dark side
and he's not the only villain we see in
this trailer but
yes to get it out of the way the very
first face we see in the snyder cut
justice league trailer
is darkseids we've heard a lot about
time travel being a part of this new cut
of the story
and it looks like we'll be seeing one
future where darkseid destroys the earth
within the first 15 seconds of the
trailer we get a glimpse of what appears
to be a destroyed justice league
headquarters
parademons swarm towards what remains of
an obliterated city
as spaceships rain fire down on the last
of what was human civilization
we also get a shot of the updated
steppenwolf in full armor
as well as our first glimpse of
darkseid's right-hand man
dassan who appears in a hooded cloak
that's everything we've seen so far
we have not however glimpsed any sign of
martian manhunter
lex luthor or the green lantern corps
but you wouldn't want everything given
away in a single trailer
would you check out one of our newest
videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one